ما زالت تحت قوه الزلزال بلغت سبعه درجات
يستعرض تفاصيل الزلزال المغرب
لماذا فوجئ علماء الجيولوجيا بزلزال
المغرب تحدث الزلازل عاده في المناطق
الواقعه عند الصفائح التكتونيه وهو ما
يجعل دولا مثل تركيا واندونيسيا والياباني
مهدده بها دائما في حين تقع منطقه المغرب
العربي اقصى شمال الصفيحه التكتونيه
الافريقيه ما يجعلها عرضه للزلازل ايضا
لكن على نحو متفاوت الجزائر في مقدمه
الاكثر نشاطا والمغرب ثانيا بنشاط زلزالي
متوسط لكن المفاجاه التي حيرت العلماء في
الزلزال الاخير كانت في مكان حدوثه فاذا
كانت الزلازل تحدث عاده على اطراف الصفائح
نتيجه احتكاكها مع صفيحه المجاوره فقد
حدثت هذه المره داخل الصفيحه كذلك فان مثل
هذا النوع من الحركه يكون بطيئا عاده ما
يجعل من درجه قوه الزلزال مفاجئا